good morning to you senior ministers
will meet today to finalise plans for
the next stage of lockdown in england
with it now
all but certain that the easing of
restrictions on the 21st of june
will be set back boris johnson has
admitted he's
less optimistic about further reopening
as he holds final talks with members of
his cabinet before addressing the nation
tomorrow
now it's reported the easing of controls
could be delayed by about four weeks so
that would allow more people to get a
second dose of vaccine
as cases of the delta variant continue
to rise
but as ashley hurinag reports it's bad
news for business
hoping to fully reopen soon
there have been next to no laughs at
this comedy club in kingston for 18
months
with only room for 60 it's intimate
venues like this
relying on the country breaking free
from restrictions
it doesn't exist if we can't have people
come into a space and be together so but
of course you know we want people to do
it safely i'm not advocating anything
that would be unsafe but
we don't exist if we can't be performing
in this because we never know what's
going to happen until right before
then we have to go okay well what are
they going to throw at us this time is
it going to be one meter is it going to
be a meter and a half distance you know
what's the mask rule
not having any guidance in advance is
crucial to making a good decision that's
safe for us
and safe for our customers this
frustration the prime minister will
likely face from thousands of businesses
especially as promises of so-called
freedom day in england
are being scaled back it's clear that
the cases are going up
and that the levels of hospitalization
are going up clearly it's a matter of
serious serious concern no
lesson from where you were at the end of
may that's fair isn't it
yes that's certainly fair but this won't
necessarily mean
returning to lockdown scientists are
unlikely to suggest that restrictions
should be tightened further but there
are signs that some rules will be here
to stay
things like face masks and guidance on
working from home
in order to make the road map
irreversible the answer may be more jabs
in arms
the double vaccinated are far better
protected but just over half of adults
in the uk have had both doses
a few weeks delay buys more time
if there is a delay i think the majority
of people
are actually already wanting it to
happen
and the data suggests that quite clearly
i think the danger is
that the government acts a bit like like
a parent who thinks that the public
aren't capable of dealing with the truth
and can't be told the full
information don't treat the public as
fools
and don't treat the public as a problem
treat the public
as a partner tomorrow is decision day
but it's likely june the 21st will be a
summer solstice
that may feel far from celebratory
ashnaharenac
sky news so david attenborough will
today tell g7 leaders
they face some of the most important
decisions in human history
it comes on the final day of the summit
in cornwall as the group prepares to set
out commitments to tackle climate change
and as dan whitehead reports the
environmentalist is not the only one at
the summit
pushing for action on the summit's final
day
it is the oceans and climate taking the
spotlight
here now anyway in falmouth a flotilla
of campaigners took to the seas
calling on leaders to take action
two of the major ones that would be an
incredible start would be
actually well banning heavy fuel oil but
if they're not going to ban it at least
tax it
the other big thing that would be
wonderful would be banning
bottom trawling the carbon emissions
just from bottom trawling
one subsection of fishing is greater
than global aviation
the demands come as g7 leaders announced
a new finance deal
to tackle international climate
challenges in some of the world's
poorest countries
the scheme aims to give developing
nations faster
access to cash for things like renewable
energy projects
but there are also some big
announcements for the g7
on how to better protect our oceans
the uk government has announced a 500
million pound fund
to protect marine biodiversity in
countries like ghana
indonesia and pacific island states
the announcements on climate action come
after two days of protests in cornwall
and there is skepticism about any
commitments these leaders make
the steps that we need now in our
climate crisis are so big that the
anything that they come up with we're
just not
optimistic often in summits they they
like to produce big statements don't
they
and grand ideas but whether they'll
actually keep to them
i don't know i'm here because i want it
to be so that when he's
20 people need to be here because
something's been done
those pushing governments for action say
big promises
need big investment we absolutely
welcome the initiative
although it really needs to come with
hard financial commitments we keep
seeing again and again
promises being made like the 100 billion
goal for
um developing countries to act on
climate change
and there's just still not enough
finance to to deliver that
the climate change message has dominated
protests this weekend
as the g7 summit draws to a close
message they're projecting is loud and
clear
[Music]
dan white is sky news in falmouth
cornwall
well tensions over post-brexit trading
arrangements
in northern ireland have played out at
the g7 summit the prime minister telling
sky news yesterday that eu leaders
need to get it into their heads that
northern ireland is part of the uk
but there is hope amongst some that an
intervention from president biden could
provide a way forward
the irish prime minister says a
veterinary type agreement with the eu
called an sps could eliminate up to 80
per cent of checks on goods
he's been talking to our senior island
correspondent david blevins
i think we need to move beyond where we
are uh i think
from my understanding of a lot of the
technical issues that have been
discussed progress can be made on quite
a lot of the issues
i believe the us administration's
comments
last week which were released
are interesting as well and so far as
they deal with a significant issue that
would concern the british government i.e
the capacity to do a trade deal with the
united states
whilst also having uh an sps
arrangement between the european union
and the united kingdom and in my view
uh there's a legitimate issue there for
you you're like in government
but in our view an sps agreement would
deal with up to 80 percent of all of
these
issues and i think it's a surprise what
uh
certainly exploring in the fullest
manner possible
to what extent do you understand the us
administration chastise the british
government
for the perceived threat at least to the
peace process
and do you believe president biden
perhaps has a further role to play in
help
helping to broker a solution i wouldn't
see it as a chastisement
that i think the u.s president is very
clear on restoring the transatlantic
relationship between america and
the european union and america and the
united kingdom he's also then of course
as we know
absolutely committed to the good friday
agreement the full walking of the
institutions of the good friday
agreement
and he doesn't want discussions around
the protocol
uh to to undermine the good friday
agreement and and he also wants to see
full engagement and he believes there's
a way and a root as i do
to getting these issues resolved time is
not on your side now
if there is no deal by the first of july
and the british government unilaterally
for a third time extends the grace
period this time for chilled mates
to avoid this so-called sausage war what
way would you expect the eu to respond
to that i think it'll be very
problematic because it's not about
sausages per se
it really is about the fact that an
agreement had been entered into not too
long ago
signed off by the british government
with the european union the trade and
cooperation agreement
including the withdrawal agreement and
the protocol and that creates
if just consistent unilateral deviation
from that agreement
that clearly undermines the broader
relationship between the european union
and the united kingdom which is in
nobody's interest
so just to be clear you believe sps
agreement is neither solution
and would you be hopeful that because
president biden has assured the british
government
that that wouldn't prevent a trade deal
that they may now
consider that seriously i think it is a
significant part of the solution
i think they should consider it very
seriously and i think it could lead
um to a breakthrough on this
well let's talk to our political
correspondent rob powell i mean and
the implication there rob is that if
boris johnson wants to resolve this he
may have to consider
signing up to more eu rules would that
even be palatable to him
well i think if you judge boris johnson
by his words and actions over the last
few years you'd have to say that would
be quite unlikely because he's
continuously rejected signing the uk up
to eu laws in this sort of agri-food
area saying that it wouldn't really mean
that we're taking back control
of our laws i think when you combine
that with the stormy rhetoric that we've
had around
northern ireland with the eu at this g7
summit that maybe
makes you think that a compromise is
less likely
many newspapers reporting that emmanuel
macron the french president
yesterday in his bilateral meeting with
the prime minister
somewhat frustrated downing street by
suggesting that northern ireland wasn't
really
a proper part of the united
kingdom i think two big things have
changed though compared to when
boris johnson signed that brexit
withdrawal agreement in 2019
the first and this is what miho martin
was uh getting at in that interview
there
is the man in the white house joe biden
is a lot more sympathetic
um to the eu than his predecessor to put
it mildly
and would be a lot more accommodating of
these sorts of requirements and eu rules
in the uk when it came to a u.s uk
trade deal and i think the other factor
as well um
is that boris johnson is in a different
position politically here in westminster
than he was in 2019
he has a big majority brexit is less of
a high profile issue it's considered
more of a closed issue
now around these parts so if he did make
this big compromise and it would be a
very big compromise
by signing up to these rules he may well
face less fire and fury from his back
benches
well let's just return to our top story
this morning and the prime minister's
very strong hint that the full reopening
on june 21st
could be delayed it comes amid growing
concern over the spread of the delta
variant which public health england says
now makes up more than 90 percent of new
cases
in the uk well let's talk to deepti
gudasani a clinical epidemiologist and
senior lecturer at queen mary university
of uh london hospital good to see you
this morning
look let's get a straight answer to
begin with should we be reopening on
june the 21st or not
no i mean there's been a scientific
consensus on this that has been very
clear for weeks even before stage three
reopening
sage on may 13th warned that going ahead
with stage three
could lead to a level of hospitalization
similar to the january wave if we had a
highly transmissible variant and going
ahead with stage four would make the map
make the whole thing considerably worse
so sage independence have been very very
clear for a while so it's curious to see
why
the government has tweeted this is
ambiguous and
said the data isn't clear and is coming
to this decision quite late
i mean where does the vaccine play in
all of this i mean there's
there's one approaching 30 million
people fully vaccinated now
um is that not making significant
inroads
it's certainly going to make a
difference so it's going to weaken the
link between
cases and hospitalizations but we need
to remember that we have only 42 percent
of our entire population that's been
fully vaccinated and we're dealing with
a variant which has a significant level
of escape
that means one dose doesn't provide a
high level of protection and two doses
while they provide a high level of
protection that level of protection is
still a little bit lower than before
and that means that you know as we see
cases rise
exponentially which they are they're
doubling every nine days we're also
seeing hospitalizations rise
particularly in the northwest where this
sort of began earlier
and now we are seeing rises and
hospitalizations across england
so while vaccines will weaken that link
unfortunately they may not be able to
prevent
a surge that's significant for the nhs
and you know for the people who are
affected okay look
when we talk about these things we've
talked about them a lot of course over
the last few months people come out with
an
argument that say look the most
vulnerable the most clinically
vulnerable people
have been vaccinated younger people
particularly school children
are less likely to be badly affected by
the virus now
do any of these arguments actually
matter in terms of what happens with the
virus how it progresses how it mutates i
mean
can we have any sense of being able to
sit back with a degree of confidence
well certainly not because yes the most
vulnerable have had a high level of
protection with vaccination that
protection is still not 100
we need to remember for example the 28
of the debts for the delta variant
were among people who are fully
vaccinated and that's far lower than
they would have been
if we didn't have this level of
vaccination but people who've been
vaccinated can still die
and younger people of course are still
vulnerable
and if infected in sufficient numbers
even though their individual risk is low
the number of hospitalizations and
deaths can still be quite high
the risk of long covert is also very
significant given it's very common in
young healthy people
who are the group that's being rapidly
infected very very quickly in large
numbers right now
you know we already have one million
people living with this and one in five
people
will go on and develop persistent
symptoms for five weeks or more and we
don't know what the long term
consequences are
and the risk of virus adaptation is very
very real
university of cambridge research showed
that the best way to fuel
escape mutants was to have high levels
of transmission
along with vaccination of a vulnerable
population so we have
a population that's mixing and
transmitting
that's unprotected alongside a partially
protected
uh population that's vulnerable and uh
you know we can't think this is the end
of the line in terms of mutations
there's no reason that should be the
case
and we need to protect ourselves against
this because it's very possible that
these viruses will adapt towards
escaping vaccines even more
and the damage that could do to our
pandemic response which is largely based
on vaccines
could be huge because it could take us
very much back to square one or even
before that
and the only way to prevent virus
adaptation is to
prevent transmission and control
transmission and also to put in
comprehensive
controls at our borders to prevent
import of new variants because we have
no idea where the next variant will come
from
okay dr kudasani good to talk to you
this morning thank you
that's a bit depressing isn't it but
realistic nonetheless
okay let's cheer ourselves up a little
bit this morning take you outside
into the sky garden to see what the
weather's doing i wish they'd let me out
now why would they let me outside
i don't know you need to ask the bosses
but i'm allowed outside
just to double check that my forecast is
correct and i can tell you there's blue
skies above me
it is going to be a widely warm day all
four home counties of the uk
are likely to see the highest
temperature of the year so far
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
morning so it is going to be warm across
most of the uk and ireland
for today and it stays quite warm in
fact locally hot
over the next few days across some parts
of the south but gradually it will
become cloudier and cooler from the
north in fact across northwestern parts
of the uk
uh this morning north west scotland
mainly it is quite cloudy with some
spells of rain there rather windy too
elsewhere it's a mild morning mainly dry
and bright and plenty of sunshine
continuing into this afternoon as well
the strong may sunshine is going to get
to work
temperatures are going to rocket up
we're going to see widely highs over
the early 20s up to around locally some
spots in the southeast 28 to 29 degrees
celsius if we get higher than 28.3
degrees celsius that will make it the
highest temperature of the year so far
also
it will make it the highest ever
temperature recorded for the 13th
of june the 13th of june is the only day
in the whole of meteorological summer
that has never exceeded a temperature
higher than 30 degrees celsius but
northwest scotland cloudy and wet
the same for northwest island and
northern ireland later
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now with the g7 drawing to an end
president biden and the first lady will
take
tea with the queen at windsor castle
this afternoon it's an honour that goes
back many years
with her majesty hosting 14 presidents
our royal correspondent rihanna mills
looks ahead to the meeting today
they already appear to have hit it off
it was all smiles as the queen met the
bidens on friday
but after sharing that time with the
other g7 leaders
now they will get their own private
moment with the monarch
by coming to windsor the bidens follow
the trumps the obamas george w bush and
his wife
and the reagans and just like his
predecessors
president biden will be so aware of how
important the pictures are going to be
when it comes to the overall coverage
of his first overseas visit for an
audience back home who
cannot get enough of the royal family
eisenhower was the first she hosted as
queen in 69 years she's seen 13 american
presidents
come and go some visits
sparking genuine friendships
others more controversial great woman
democratic strategist laura fink
believes her majesty's
14th president will see this as a huge
honor
how do you think it's likely to play out
between president biden
and the queen well it was funny because
with president trump he said it's the
best time she's had in 25 years
following the event and so i think that
was characteristic of his bombast i
think we're going to do
it's going to be a 180 with president
biden he is
understated he is someone who connects
with people on a deeply personal level
cementing those shared interests started
on friday the duchess of cambridge and
dr jill biden
teaming up for a school visit and yes
boris johnson has certainly put in the
hours at the g7 summit
but lord derek who was the uk's
ambassador in washington during the
trump administration
says nothing compares to the queen's
subtle influence
there is just a uh an extraordinary
fascination
which is very lucky for us that means a
huge and huge national asset as i say
uh and helps greatly i think it's part
of soft power diplomacy
a big part yes there will be foreign
office briefing
provided for her and she will read it
and she will
get it all and she will she will pack it
away and that will be part of
uh the material for her conversation
with him
but she's just so experienced in doing
this
and sure she can manage without the
briefing but she will take the briefing
she will absorb it
in cornwall we saw in spades what a
moment
with the monarch means now in this
historic setting
president biden will receive a
significant diplomatic pat on the back
or conducted over a simple cup of tea
riannon mills sky news at windsor castle
now as leaders met in cornwall this
weekend there's been a push to help low
and middle income countries vaccinate
their populations with pledges of up to
a billion
covered vaccines be provided by the g7
to these poorer countries
let's talk to fergus drake who's chief
executive of crown agents
a company helping to distribute covert
vaccines across the world good to see
you this morning now
clearly getting those vaccines
themselves
is important but it's no good just just
providing a company like you with with
hundreds of millions of doses is it
because presumably
that the logistics here are particularly
difficult
that's right these recent vaccine
pledges could be the g7's biggest
success
since its inception in 1975 or its
biggest missed opportunity because what
we don't want to see
is millions of vaccines going to waste
because the infrastructure
and the planning hasn't been able to
happen on the ground over the next
critical
few months it's really important as you
say to know that a vaccine is only
half cesary every vaccine needs the
right syringe every syringe needs a
fully trained community health worker to
administer it
those health workers need ppe and above
all there needs to be a willing
arm at the end of that chain to receive
the vaccine yeah
i mean look even on on the basics i know
obviously president biden's
pledged you know hundreds of millions of
doses of the fisa vaccine now for for a
lot of these poorer countries you know
it's
it's that's a cold storage problem isn't
it
for a lot of them even just to to store
that vaccine for any length of time
that's right so there are four key
issues the first is that these vaccines
need to arrive
quickly and they need to have a long
shelf life and also they can't arrive
all at once because if there's millions
that arrive in a country like south
sudan
then the infrastructure simply can't
cope and it'll be a bit like taking a
drink of water through a fire hose
secondly that's that coal chain
infrastructure that you talked about
pfizer needs to be um passed on a kind
of minus 70 to minus 80 degrees
and so when it arrives in country it
needs to go from a capital city to a
regional center
to local primary healthcare units and it
needs to stay within
that cold chain finally you need the
health workers
they need to have training but they also
need the specific medical equipment so
not only
personal protective equipment but the
pfizer vaccine has its own syringe and
they have been in short supply
over the last few months and then a bit
like the uk
you need pro vaccine messages you need
to use social media you need to
use local opinion formers like we did so
successfully
over the last year to ensure that many
people are
turning up at these primary healthcare
units to take these jobs when they
arrive
so when you outline it like that it does
seem to be
actually a huge astronomical problem
in terms of of how to get these jabs out
and say never mind getting the arms to
put them in
the willing arms to put them in how long
a process
is this going to be we're not just going
to be able to get this out
in the next 12 months are we well it is
going to take some time but there is a
window of opportunity
now if we get the funding right we can
have
everyone standing by so i like to use
the analogy of a formula one pit stop
when you've got everyone trained a car
arrives it can be refueled and all four
tires changed
in under three seconds that's what we
need to happen when these vaccines
arrive on ground
uh people like the ministry of health
national governments organizations like
garvey
unicef ourselves faith-based
organizations charities need to be
standing by
to ensure that we have one overall cold
chain we have the right people who've
been trained up
and then we can really crack on with
getting this done over the next 12
18 months i mean are you confident that
can happen
fergus i think it's going to be an
absolutely unprecedented feat but i am
optimistic with the pledges that have
happened
but the pledges aren't enough there
needs to be the funding that sits around
that
there needs to be organizations with
specific skills who are working
alongside the the global organizations
to ensure that we don't get
any countries left behind because my
overall concern is that covert
could become the next residual panader
pandemic so what i mean by that
is hiv aids still kills over 700
000 people every year but we don't talk
about that in western
societies the kind of narrative has
moved on we can't have that becoming the
overall
end point of covet going forward yeah
it's really good to torture this morning
fergus thanks very much
indeed thank you okay time to have a
look at the papers for you this morning
with
the press association's political
correspondent jerry scott and patrick
winter the guardians diplomatic editor
good to see you both
once again let's start with um
the sunday mirror jerry should we um
with the prime minister
she's adding fuel to the fire with this
eu rail
yes neither side seems to be backing
down do they on this uh
intensifying row over the northern
ireland um protocol and
you know the the prime minister has said
that really he's not going to hesitate
in triggering what's known as article 16
which is
really seen as the nuclear option we saw
the eu use it
in january i believe it was over
vaccines but it basically means that
either side can decide to kind of
suspend or rip up
the agreement that is in place over over
the border um and you know this is
really coming to a head now because
restrictions are due to
kind of end order sorry the grace period
is due to end at the end of
this month we don't really know what's
going to happen the trust has completely
broken down between
the two sides and uh neither side seemed
to want to budge there's a very there's
a big round about
how purist to be about the enforcement
of the northern ireland protocol
and it just really seems like there is
going to be
a ratcheting up of tensions until it
finally
blows there was quite an interesting
anecdote in one of the papers
about boris johnson saying that he had
to kind of prove or
explain to some of the eu leaders that
northern ireland and britain were in the
same country
that wasn't quite understood so it seems
like there's still a way to go until we
get to agreement
yeah yeah it would seem so sunday
telegraph patrick looking at
china and the uyghur muslims who
i mean over here we hear about
periodically but we're not
fully aware really are we of just the
scale of what's going on
exactly i mean this is a really
impressive piece of on the ground
reporting the telegraph i think they say
it's part of a four
day um investigation and their reporter
and then sophie young have been
up in the province for nine days i think
with another group of reporters and it's
a very
tough uh piece of work trying to
break into a surveillance state like
this one
and uh i think it's uh she gives a very
good
vivid picture of the sense of fear and
the sense of state control
in this province and also the way in
which so many
um muslim
mosques have been destroyed there's one
story about one very large mosque that's
been
torn down it should begin to be replaced
by a hilton
hotel uh and the way in which a whole
culture is being
gradually wiped out but the the good
twist in her report is the way in which
the chinese state is trying to
soften some of the most repressive
measures and
that she says is a sign that the chinese
government are very confident that
they've brought what they regarded as
rebellion under control
this is all very germane to hear the g7
in cornwall because they're discussing
what to do about china and uh joe
biden's pressing that the community
cares a lot more about
forced labour and ching zhang
this is chris to the mill but it's a
very good piece of reporting
yeah well it's interesting for us on to
the sunday express jerry
somewhat doesn't it but the idea boris
johnson seems to think that
that you know the west is back after the
g7 summit
and providing a suitable opposition at
least to the
the the power surge that china is
there does seem to want to be this
united front and there as patrick says
this is being
discussed at the g7 both on the slave
labor type
the side of things the origins of
coronavirus as well but also
the kind of global infrastructure spend
um the g7 countries are likely to say
you know
that they all back this uh build back
better for the world
uh scheme that uh johnson has kind of
spearheaded
including you know railways in africa
and wind farms in asia and things like
that and
that is a direct com in competition to
china's own
global infrastructure development plans
which of course we know
provides them with influence and what
will be interesting to see is just
how strong these joint statements are it
does seem like you know president
biden's very
keen to be very strong on this eu
leaders maybe
not so much so what that final statement
what about final communication looks
like
i think is going to be very interesting
but it does seem like there's a
united front here as you say boris
johnson is very keen
to stress that the west and liberal
democracies are up for the fight
do you know what it's been a weekend of
some very heavy and very serious news so
should we
should we lighten things up a bit
because you know what people like you
too they're like a dog story
oh we've got a couple for you patrick
let's have a look at yours
in the sun on sunday looking at um
our favorite dog owner her majesty the
queen seems to got herself a new corgi
yes i have to admit this isn't my
specialist area but
um i did enjoy the story because um
i have as i've become more advanced in
years become
an ever greater admirer of the queen and
she's been
tremendous down here at the g7 and to
come down tall and i think she still has
kind of
star quality and her longevity is
just astonishing but anyway this is just
a story about apparently her
previous call he was quite young called
fergus's
died and now uh other members of the
royal family have given her a new puppy
and there's a nice little headline one
mom and her
dog it's a great headline and
you know um i suppose it's mom's best
friend and all that
um the the issue in the story
not the research issue in the story
really is what it should be called
and um as they haven't given it a name
yet and i was wondering whether megan
would be a nice
oh controversial controversial i knew
you were going to say that yeah true
you're a sneaky troublemaker patrick
really
um jerry let's let's have a look at the
sunday times because the high street is
going to welcome dog owners
uh sort of to try and boost trade and
that's a that's a sensible move isn't it
yeah i think so you know like like her
majesty lots of people have had new
puppies during lockdown we've seen them
all over social media haven't we so
a lot of people have got dogs now we
know that people are very concerned
about dog nappings they want to take
their pets
into shops also i feel like when you go
abroad you see people able to take their
dogs absolutely everywhere and it's
always been
crazy to me that we've been so anti-dog
in so many ways so
um yes i mean shops are obviously keen
to get people back in after the package
it's a really great really sensible move
i think